[Music]
you rule the rule is simple get with the
times
Oh how many of these are you gonna make
Felix huh how many of these worry gonna
possibly make that's Manny is a goddamn
please let's get this party started
let's get this party started a classic
example of a loud equals funny nurse ma
two shots of vodka then one the real two
shots of vodka oh [ __ ] it's okay that is
two shots of vodka it's the Russian
metric system okay that is that is
actually accurate so this is not even
funny we shout
[Music]
they're [ __ ] smiling that's a
beautiful smile how does he do it no
scam
okay so let's not beat around the bush
this show is actually really great so
far and has a lot of potential that said
hopefully it won't keep up the age-old
a-1 pictures tradition of starting out
promising and then
[Music]
I know which any one of them oh good
hell yeah I'm feeling this one oh damn
schools got some pretty good taste
Phantasy Star Online terraria Tekken
okay how do you even drop a juggle like
that you're a ghost bound to a room with
nothing to do all day but eat pudding
and play video games and you drop an air
juggle after three [ __ ] hits no I'm
not even gonna give you that it was two
quick jabs and a bounce and you dropped
at the bounce wouldn't have even kept
the combo going you would've just slam
Nina into the ground right after to
light jabs to piss-poor damage
kasnia is built specifically for juggles
and you uppercut jab jab into a [ __ ]
bounce juggle starter and what is this a
mid gut punch into a back she's rolling
around on the ground or you just mash
you square and triangle you guys good
yeah well done I don't know where that's
from but well then to be honest I was
really looking forward to watch this
anime and now I don't know how to feel
uh-oh that sounds like Swiper the Fox
that sneaky Fox is always trying to
swipe our stuff
a full version please that was
incredible I've seen this like why does
he keep is it part of their act why do
they keep falling stop falling this one
I see all the time it's so [ __ ] weird
see you don't have a lifeguard here at
your Beach the acting is just so good I
think Tommy Wiseau directed this one
I'm not into beaches a bathtub come on
Lady I see you don't have a lifeguard
here at your Beach no body of water is
safe without a lifeguard it's to be
deeply you can relax
you're safe now your lifeguard is here
[Music]
no shocking man I think you're playing
aren't you glad you're a lifeguard here
to save you yes it's so weird
I don't get it what the hell happened
what happened there
stop the [ __ ] car [ __ ] [ __ ] die
stop the [ __ ] car
are you surveillance come on dude you're
cancer you hi
I'm sure answer what how do the [ __ ] did
we get out this far [ __ ] no more gas
[Music]
Oh
oh this guy's alleged [ __ ] no more guess
no hey
that was good good one okay how to make
a triple a game aside I think there's
one is they trying to say hey you want
the whole game you gotta get the season
pass man come on man don't be silly take
one piece oh wow how nice of them to add
that in forest masterpiece well that was
pretty that's pretty accurate I would
say well dad do I look like I know what
a Japanese movie would I was close that
one was close I give you that one
well then do I look like I know what a
JPEG news
it's not even like I know what a JPEG
news so the idea of this game is you
have to try and draw penis using your
voice in the wave files and it's bloody
hard guys I'm gonna have a call that's
not a bad penis yes oh man I gotta try
this I gotta try this okay Oh No [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that's enough girly penis let me
turn it again [ __ ] this is hard
[Music]
that's not a bad person I'm getting
there I'm getting there I'm getting
there
oh [ __ ]
oh I knew it I knew I knew I had the
talent that mushroom head is perfect my
gut I knew I had the talent Ernest
Lagasse you don't have a lifeguard here
at your Beach my patty of water is safer
than a lifeguard not that funny
that was another episode of you hope you
enjoyed this episode as always a like as
appreciated remember to hit a subscribe
it really helps me out
super much I thank you if you have fun
in video I now make a reddit and you can
submit funny video if you want to make
me haha so so definitely yes send send
me stuff cuz I'm not gonna I'm tired of
looking it up myself okay I'm tired of
doing all the work for these videos
thank you very much I'm sick of it I'm
sick of it well you think oh this one
wasn't that funny okay will you prove me
wrong send me something actually funny
okay huh huh how about that you thought
about that for you [ __ ] about it thank
you so much don't love you guys so much
out